[Music]
I'm skating with these women I feel on
fire I love roller skating so much that
I decided that I was going to bring it
back for everyone
I'm the South Island better known as
Esther den and I'm the founder of Moxie
roller skates there are 21 skaters on
the Moxie skating worldwide but some of
them are pigeon Indy Jimmy John's smelly
and legs anything that's experimental or
outside of what you've probably seen on
roller skates is what we do roller
skating was really really big until I
was born and then it really kind of
dropped off when rollerblades came in
roller skate innovation just stopped
roller derby was the next new court to
come to the roller skating industry the
states that they were selling the roller
derby skaters were made for speed
the skates that we're making now are
made for secure landing for high-flying
tricks you know a few years ago there
were like scowl stealing backflips and
on their own wheel and now there are and
I'm amazed at what my body can do I
really am
we are chasing our dreams we're chasing
that feeling that wonderful floaty
feeling of being wise and you will get
that firm roller spinning it's this
strange new feeling that's refreshing
oh this is dreadful